[Musique]
pierre connaa bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle ser
on voudrait votre vision de la
géopolitique mondiale et de la
géostratégie de la parole diplomatique
française qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en
dire c'est une question qui est un peu
vaste pour traiter dans une interview
mais en peu de mot j'ai l'impression que
la France continue à se poser comme
puissance moyenne alors qu'elle est
devenue à mon avis une pays de moyen
impuissance c'est-à-dire qu'il a un
décalage entre le discours et la réalité
é des moyens bon simplement c'est
extrêmement difficile à prendre en
compte parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait réexaminer toute une partie de
notre diplomatie pour que véritablement
nos intérêts s'ajuste avec ce que nous
prétendons pouvoir jouer comme
rôle un des exemples les plus classiques
étant évidemment cette espèce de comment
dire de logo qu'on met systématiquement
en avant en disant la France pays des
droits de l'homme enfin on sait très
bien que quand on combat DAEs pour
défendre l'Arabie Saoudite on voit bien
que c'est pas la politique des droits de
l'homme qui guide notre notre choix bon
donc arriver à quelque chose qui soit un
peu plus près de la réalité de nos
intérêts et surtout qu'on cesse de
donner des leçons à la planète entière
sur les droits de l'homme quand on
oublie l'Arabie Saoudite dans la liste
ça fait partie de ces réévaluations qui
pourrait se faire comment vous
jugez la position de Jean-Marc hraud et
de l'Arabie Saoudite plus en
détail Jean-Marc HUD est pas
spécialement un un homme qui qui a
jusqu'à maintenant marquer une
diplomatie particulière à G de l'Arabie
Saoudite il y a une longue continuité de
relation de la France avec l'Arabie
Saoudite le premier voyage en fait
officiel français en Arabie Saoudite
c'est 67 le général de Gaul il avait
prévu puis il y a eu les événements de
68 ça pas pu se faire bon mais c'était
la prise en compte du fait qu'il y avait
un pays qui était un pays qui sur le
plan énergétique était très important
mais ce qui sur le plan géopolitique
paraissait un espèce d'acteur mineur
hein puisque c'était l'Arabie Saoudite
des années 67 bon simplement on a
effectivement dans la région du Golfe
plutôt d'ailleurs sur les émirals Qatar
et autres eu des très gros contrats
moins sur l'Arabie Saoudite mais il y a
toujours l'idée que l'Arabie Saoudite
est un espèce de client qu'il faut
ménager parce que il y a toujours une
perspective de 10 milliards de contrats
en cours de signature moi depuis que je
m'occupe de l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est-à-dire depuis enfin quand j'ai
commencé dans les années
9992 on avait déjà 10 milliards de
contrats en perspective bon ce qu'on
appelle la la prospective glissante hein
c'est pas grave il suffit de reporter à
chaque fois laattente de de contrat mais
c'est pour dire qu'il y a de de gros
contrats de temps en temps avec l'Arabie
Saoudite qui touch au domaine du BTP des
de l'armement de l'énergie et cetera
mais il reste que le discours euh la
condition de ce de ces contrats c'est
effectivement l'extraordinaire mutisme
sur les droits de l'homme en Arabie
Saoudite donc hos ne changera pas
grand-chose à mon avis à cette politique
là il continuera à être celle du du
réalisme mais si effectivement on
baissait d'un ton sur la question des
droits de l'homme à chaque fois qu'on a
l'occasion de le sortir ce serait un peu
plus cohérent nous sommes allés la
semaine des ambassadeurs organisé par le
ked d'orset vous avez vu notre fameuse
vidéo tog life à près de 300000 vues hm
hm quel est votre avis sur cette vidéo
notre action est-ce que c'était légitime
qu'on se déplace pour poser ce type de
question est-ce que vous comprenez
pourquoi on nous a répondu en première
réponse qu'on ne voyait pas la la
relation entre le sujet du débat et
notre question non la question est
d'autant plus légitime qu'effectivement
ça fait partie de ces contradictions
extraordinaires c'est-à-dire on va se
lever les bras au ciel à chaque fois
qu'il y a une exécution publique en Iran
mais le jour où il y en a 45 en Arabie
Saoudite dont un un imam chiit qui n'a
rien fait si ce n'est contesté le régime
en demandant simplement les même droit
pour les chites que pour les sunites
c'était l'unique revendication qu'on se
thèse là-dessus c'est fantastique que
pour raev badaou on a droit à une
question orale d'un député d'un sénateur
madame Goulet sur qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire pour essayer de sauver ce prof-
type qui est quand même condamné à 1000
coups de fouet et 10 ans de prison moi
je crois qu'on peut négocier sur les 10
ans de prison parce que le type sera
mort au bout des 1000 coups de fouet
donc toute façon au moins on peut
obtenir qu'il ne fasse pas ses années de
prison mais on en est dans ce cynisme là
c'est-à-dire que quelque chose qui
encore une fois à l'égard de l'Arabie
Saoudite et de la est une espèce de de
faillite de comment dire de notre ligne
diplomatique pour ce qui concerne cette
espèce de encore une fois de de
publicité continuellement répété sur la
France pays des droits de l'homme en
permanent du Conseil de sécurité donc
moi je me souviens d'un article d'un
grand quotidien du soir qui allait au
moment où le président actuel est arrivé
au pouvoir disait le président Hollande
veut changer de portage et donc va
abandonner le Qatar pour choisir
l'Arabie Saoudite ciel nous étions
effectivement dans un grand
bouleversement de la politique
extérieure on est on est dans une on est
encore une dans quelque chose qui fait
que ce serait vivable si l'Arabie
Saoudite n'était pas le moteur
générateur du du salafisme partout sur
la planète là maintenant on est face à
un principe de réalité si on veut
arrêter le salafisme il faut se poser la
question de l'Arabie Saoudite on nous a
répondu en deuxième réponse que l'Arabie
Saoudite participait à la lutte contre
le terrorisme que l'Arabie Saoudite
avait été frappée sur son sol aussi par
le des actes terroristes hm
hm bah c'est vrai enfin l'Arabie
Saoudite euh
euh a été frappée sur son sol elle a été
frappée par les radicaux qu'elle a
elle-même formé parce que rappelez-vous
les premiers attentats sur l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est Al-Qaïda c'est Ben Laden
qui justement reproche au régime d'avoir
d'en avoir appelé au mécréant pour le
sauver et ça c'est une contradiction
structurelle de l'Arabie Saoudite c'est
que c'est un régime qui a été constitué
à sa naissance par une dynastie les
saoudes et par une famille les alcher
c'est-à-dire les descendants d'abdal
Wahab et donc ces deux entités gèrent la
grosse PME familiale qui est l'Arabie
Saoudite et à chaque fois que la la
dynastie pour sauver sa tête en appel au
mécréant ça s'est fait en 91 ça s'est
fait en 79 pour laoccupation de la
grande mosquée et cetera et ça se fait
encore aujourd'hui à chaque fois la
dynastie doit se tourner vers sesouema
pour qu'il lui trouve une bonne
explication théologique pour cette
trahison donc sesulema étant aussi
habile que nos gésuites pour arriver à
trouver des explications en échange le
dynastie doit leur donner plus de moyens
et ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé moi quand
j'ai écrit mon bouquin c'est que des
gens qui étaient allés en Arabie
Saoudite il y a 50 ans des femmes en
particulier disaient mais à l'époque les
occidentals n'étaient pas obligés de se
voir aller elle pouvait sortir les bras
nus il y avait des cinémas et cetera or
au fur et à mesure ces Oulé ont gagné de
plus en plus de pouvoirs sur la société
civile saoudienne qui fait que par
exemple à chaque fois qu'il y a eu une
crise le durcissement c'est marqué après
la crise de 91 par exemple il y a eu
plus un seul cinéma Riad fermé il y
avait plus de bibliothèque et cetera
donc vous avez ce pays extraordinaire
qui est a aujourd'hui qui est un pays
qui se caractérise par le fait qu'il y a
pas de librairie il y a pas de il y a
pas de bibliothèque il y a pas de
théâtre il y a pas de cinéma il y a pas
de centre culturel vous comprenez que
effectivement il vaut mieux aller faire
le jihad dans ce cas-là au moins on
s'amuse un peu quels sont et donc cette
cette schizophrénie de à l'égard de
l'Arabie Saoudite fait que c'est un
mécanisme structurel pour lequel en
conclusion la diplomatie religieuse
c'est un élément de l'ADN du régime donc
on peut pas essayer penser que ce régime
va arrêter de faire sa propagation du
salafisme puisque c'est la condition
même pour que les zouimas soutiennent le
régime à chaque fois qu'il en a besoin
votre dernier bouquin on l'a pas lu on n
pas le le titre parce qu'il vient de
sortir c'est ça comment s'pp il vient de
sortir ouais il est sorti a une
quinzaine de jours il y a déjà un
premier il y a un retirage de 1000 déjà
sur le en cours là donc il répond
probablement à un besoin il s'appelle
docteur Saoud et Mister jjihad la
diplomatie religieuse de l'Arabie
Saoudite parce que c'était la seule
image que j'ai trouvé pour expliquer
cette espèce de dualité de l'Arabie
saoudite où vous avez d'un côté les
saoudes qui vous reçoivent toujours très
bien qui sont très cordiaux et cetera et
cetera mais qui en fait sont tenus par
leurs zouléa de faire cette diplomatie
religieuse en peu de mots cette
diplomatie religieuse c'est près 8
milliards de dollars par an c'est-à-dire
trois fois plus que se faisait l'Union
soviétique à sa belle époque c'est entre
25000 et 30000 mecs qui ont été formés à
l'université de Médine et c'est un
espèce de générateur qui continue à
tourner simplement le générateur
commence à craquer parce que il a formé
des gens qui aujourd'hui sont en mesure
de contester les Saou Dex même
puisqu'ils estim que créer une société
islamique à l'image de daesh ça suppose
l'absence de corruption l'égalité enfin
tout ce que tout ce qui est dit dans le
discours de DA daesh mais évidemment à
conditions à laquelle Saoud ne répondent
pas donc les attentats qui ont été
provoqués sur sol saoudien sont le fait
de cette diplomatie religieuse c'est Ben
Laden à son temps et puis c'est
aujourd'hui daesh qui fait des attentats
donc dire que l'Arabie Saoudite
participe à la lutte contre le
terrorisme c'est un exercice de style
parce que contre quel terrorisme se
l'utile il lutent effectivement contre
les gens qui font du terrorisme chez eux
moi je suis toujours très amusé par la
l'analyse des universitaires qui font la
différence entre le salafisme kétiste et
le salafisme jadiste alors le salafisme
c'est c'est très simple c'est un
théologien musulman qui m'a défini ça il
m'a dit vous savez le salafisme ou le
wahabisme comme vous voulez c'est la
version la plus raciste la plus sexiste
la plus antisémite la plus misogyne la
plus homophobe et la plus sectaire de
l'islam ce qui m'a considérablement
facilité la vie puisque j'avais plus
besoin de lire les théologiens j'aical
me placer sur le terrain des idées
politiques et sur le terrain des idées
politiques le salafisme et le wabisme
c'est pareil alors qu'est-ce qui fait la
différence entre les kétistes et les
dadistes benah les quiétiste c'est
faites pas des attentats chez nous vous
pouvez les faire en Israël vous pouvez
le faire ailleurs mais en tout cas vous
faites pas sur le royaume donc ne touche
pas à mon prince c'est ça la différence
sur le salafim quiétiste mais c'est un
peu comme si on se demandait si Hitler
était un nazi kétiste avant 34 quoi
c'est à peu près la même question non
c'est une idéologie totalitaire violente
sectaire raciste tout ce qu'on veut qui
donc si jamais elle accède au pouvoir
appliquera un un système qui est
totalement intolérable et pourquoi
pourquoi Israël est le meilleur ami de
de de l'Arabie Saoudite non meilleur ami
c'est excessif c'est excessif d'abord il
faut bien reconnaître que l'Arabie
Saoudite n'a jamais combattu Israël
c'est la frontière est pas très très
éloignée parce que c'est des Sémites non
pas du tout pas du tout
euh bon d'abord la frontière n'est n'est
pas très loin et l'Arabie Saoudite n'a
jamais participé à une guerre contre
Israël ils ont envoyé une brigade en 67
mais elle est arrivé trop tard puisque
ça duré que 6 jours donc le temps
qu'elle arrive bon mais en gros ce
régime n'a jamais voulu faire la guerre
parce qu'il craignait trop pour sa
stabilité interne donc il achète des
armes mais ce sont des anxolitiques
c'est pas des armes pour se battre la
première guerre véritable que font les
saoudien c'est la guerre contre le yeman
on y reviendra si vous voulez mais il
faut comprendre pourquoi tout à coup ce
pays qui justement appeler toujours les
autres à la rescous se décide à faire la
guerre aux chiit donc aller faire la
guerre contre Israël mais c'est risqué
retour de bâton beaucoup trop grave donc
ils ont laissé tous les pays de la
périphérie se battre dans des conditions
qui parfois sont retourné au désastre
comme la guerre de 67 parfois on tournit
plus ou moins à l'avantage mais surtout
ils étaient toujours en arrière-fond
avec l'idée de pas affronter directement
Israël ils sont aujourd'hui dans une
situation où effectivement ils ont
besoin d'un allié solide parce que
les révolutions arabes qui ont touché
tous les pays de la la périphérie
l'Égypte la Syrie le bouleversement en
Irak tout ce qui a toucher le la Libye
et cetera fait qu'une grande partie des
acteurs de la région ont disparu
qu'est-ce qui reste dans le paysage qui
effectivement ont un minimum de
stabilité il y a qu'Israël donc la
Jordanie peut-être la Jordanie oui la
Jordanie aussi la Jordanie alors la
Jordanie est dans une ambigué qui tient
justement au fait que c'est un état très
fragile et qui a besoin de l'aide
saoudienne quand les quand l'ONU a
décidé l'opération aérienne contre daesh
il y avait au départ bon il y a 35 pays
mais enfin c'est du baratin je il y en
fait il y en avait en fait 16 qui
effectivement avaiit fourni des
armements pour lutter contre daesh ces
16 pays c'était 10 pays de l'OTAN plus
l'Australie et 5 pays arabes parmi
lesquel l'Arabie Saoudite le kouit enfin
bon pour donner une idée de l'importance
de mobilisation militaire de l'Arabie
Saoudite les Saoudiens mettaient autant
d'avions que le danemarque et la
Hollande réuni ce qui est effectivement
pour un pays qui a 460 avions de combat
c'est un gros ça veut dire ilils avaient
fourni une quinzaine je crois quelque
chose comme ça bon dès qu'ils ont dégagé
décidé de s'engager au Yémen contre les
chites tous les pays arabes se sont
retiré donc la Jordanie est dans une
espèce de mouvance saoudienne parce
qu'elle ne peut pas faire autrement
c'est-à-dire elle a un million de
réfugiés sur son sol donc il faut de
l'argent pour accueillir ses réfugiés et
donc le jordaniie ira toujours dans le
sens souhaité par l'Arabie Saoudite
quelle est la priorité de l'Arabie
Saoudite
aujourd'hui l'Arabie Saoudite est
contestée par un de ces monstres qui est
daesh hein c'est le docteur Frank
Einstein qui a créé un monstre qui dont
il voudrait bien qu'on le débarrasse bon
le problème dans le roman de Marie ché
c'est que le monstre il disparaît avec
le docteur mais nous on voudrait sauver
le docteur pour traiter que le monstre
et qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe
que daesh d'abord albaghdadi s'est
proclamé Calif pour le califat pour la
majorité des musulmans c'est un espèce
d'horizon mythologique historique
c'était l'âge d'or de l'islam c'est les
quatre premiers califes c'est le
succession de Mahomed c'est l'époque de
l'expansion continue de l'Islam en se
proclame l' Calif qu'est-ce qu'il dit il
dit mais Saou n'ont aucune légitimité à
tenir les lieux saints ils n'ont aucune
filiation avec le Prophète quand on
regarde la titulature d'Al Baghdadi lui
se revendique directement de la tribu
des coréchi c'est-à-dire de la tribu du
Prophète il se proclame commandeur des
croyants comme tout calife commandeur
des croyants ça veut dire commandeur des
croyants sunnites qu'il va défendre
contre les chiites de Bagdad contre les
chiites de Damas ou les alawiites de
Damas or l'Arabie Saoudite se voit
contester sur quelque chose qui est sa
légitimité première l'Arabie Saoudie
c'est un régime sunnite c'est pas un
régime musulman bon
et donc aujourd'hui l'Arabie Saoudite se
trouve contestée par quelque chose qui a
été son monstre et qu'on va et qui se
trouve donc aujourd'hui à combattre des
chites la seule manière pour l'Arabie
Saoudite de ne pas perdre sa légitimité
c'est pas de combattre daesh parce
qu'elle a trop peur pour sa pour sa
société interne le seu solution c'est de
combattre des chites pour montrer que
eux aussi défendent plus que les autres
les sunites et d'où l'attaque contre le
Yémen le yéen puisque il y avait aucune
raison et donc c'est là que vous trouvez
l'origine de ce silence des occidentaux
sur ce qui se passe au Yemen pour se
dire regardez c'est dramatique on
bombarde Halep mais je veux dire le 15
août il y a eu un bombardement par
l'aviation saoudienne d' hôpital dans
une ville du yéen s'appelle aps personne
n'en a entendu parler donc on est dans
toujours dans cette espèce de
schizophrénie où médiia explique
explication médiatique explication
politique peu importe il y a
effectivement cette espèce de tolérance
à l'égard de la de ce qui se passe en
Arabie Saoudite euh pourquoi je vous
disais que l'Arabie Saoudite craint pour
sa société interne il faut bien
comprendre que
l'Arabie Saoudite dans sa constitution
première c'estàdire dans la manière dont
le régime s'est constitué quand la
dynastie quand la tribu des saoudes
essae de conquérir l'ensemble du de la
péninsule elle va s'appuyer sur des
tribus qui sont des tribus de
l'intérieur du nage mais la colonisation
quand elle a eu lieu en dans la
péninsule tant qu'il y avait pas le
pétrole c'était une colonisation
littérale littorale pardon personne
s'occuper de ce qui se passait dans le
désert on s'en foutait bon et donc vous
aviez dans cette région des tribus qui
se disaient mais la véritable l' islam
c'est celui que nous pratiquons nous
puisque ils avaient pas changé pendant
13 siècles c'est l'origine de ce
wahabisme qui est il faut revenir à
l'islam tel qu'il était pratiqué à
l'époque et Abdel wad va fournir le
motivation du djihad pour lutter contre
les autres tribus et contre l'Empire
ottoman donc en fait dès le début dans
l'histoire nationale saoudienne le
djihad est un élément de la geste
nationale c'est Jean d'c Bayard tout ça
accumulé bon pourquoi je dis ça ça
explique que les Saoudiens étaient les
plus nombreux dans les contingents
étrangers en Afghanistan les plus N dans
les attentats du 11 septembre et les
plus nombreux aujourd'hui dans les
contingents étrangers de daesh donc
c'est difficile pour ce régime de se
battre contre daesh parce que il
risquent de leur fournir en plus des
troupes et il risquent en plus de leur
fournir des des terroristes capables de
faire des attentats sur le territoire
ils on on quand même décapité 45
récemment en place publique he parce
qu'en Arabie Saoudite c'est quand même
un spectacle bon 45 ça veut dire que
effectivement il y avait en Arabie
Saoudite des gens qui étaient prêts à
passer à l'acte ou qui étaient déjà
passés à l'acte contre ce régime donc
c'est un régime qui est fragilisé par
l'environnement qui est fragilisé par le
fait que les révolutions arabes ont
porté au pouvoir les Frères musulmans et
les Frères musulmans et l'Arabie
Saoudite s'entendent pas très bien donc
c'est un régime qu'on va probablement
porter à bout de bras et on fait son
boulot c'est-à-dire qu'on se bat contre
daesh ne me demandez pas pourquoi on se
bat contre daesh je ne sait pas si c'est
on se bat parce que il décapite il coupe
les mains des voleurs il opprime les
femmes il intertutes religion pour
défendre l'Arabie Saoudite qui coupe les
mains des voleurs qui opprime les femmes
qui décapite et qui interdit les autres
religions j'ai un petit problème de
compréhension la Syrie qu'est-ce qu'on
on peut en dire en ce moment ben la
Syrie je crois que ça a la
caractéristique de beaucoup des crises
dans lesquelles on a cru qu'on pouvait
faire de la poli faire de la police
internationale bon en gros après 91
quand disparaît l'URSS on est dans une
espèce d'euphorie qui est on sort de la
guerre du Golf les Russes ont voté
favorablement à l'intervention donc on
se dit maintenant on entre dans un monde
du droit
international appuyé par les armées de
la occidentale bon
euh en fait on va assez rapidement se
rendre compte surtout après le 11
septembre que les choses sont pas aussi
simples que ce qu'on pensait et tout ce
qui va s'enchaîner après le 11 septembre
vont être des interventions militaires
Afghanistan Irak Libye et aujourd'hui
Syrie qui vont faire faire éclater des
États qui étaient des espèces
d'impostures structurelles l'Afghanistan
c'est un pays c'est Irak Afghanistan non
pardon c'est Irak puis Afghanistan non
non c'est Afghanistan puisquil y a
l'intervention utanienne en Afghanistan
hein ensuite l'Irak ensuite la Libye et
cetera euh l'Afghanistan c'est un pays
euh qui est très bien défini par un des
chefs de guerre qui disait parce que
c'est un pays de chef de guerreghanistan
qui disait on peut pas acheter un chef
de guerre afghan mais on peut le louer
bon c'est ça c'est la logique de la
guerre en Afghanistan c'est-à-dire un
jour il est avec vous le lendemain il
peut être contre vous c'est pas grave
c'est son intérêt propre mais il y a pas
de logique de constitution d'un État
afghan parce que c'est une structure
tribale parce que chacun est armé et que
en fait c'est la police est faite par
chacun des chefs de tribu il y a un code
ethnique qui s'appelle le petoun je sais
plus comment le le le le code petoun si
vous voulez qui règle les conflits
c'estàd vous tuez un homme dans ma tribu
donc j'exige de votre part soit le
l'exécution de l'assassin soit des
remboursements en chameau en tout ce
qu'on veut bon cette régulation là a
explosé puisque rappelez-vous on est
allé pour constituer un État moderne en
Afghanistan rapide bilan plus longtemps
que les Soviétiques avec le même
présence militaire plus des sociétés
militaires de sécurité avec une
extension de la guerre au Pakistan
puisque les drones américains tu des
mecs dans la zone du
des talibans afghans bon donc je peux
pas dire c'est un succès l'Irak c'est
une catastrophe
absolue la seule sanction qu'a subi le
pauvre George buouch qui je vous le
rassure ne passera jamais dans la Cour
pénale internationale he il fait des
conférences tous les weekends où il joue
au golf ça a été un jet de chaussur par
un journaliste iraquien qui manquait
d'entraînement c'estàd qu'il l'a raté en
plus mais c'est pour dire si on est dans
cette espèce de schizophrénie qui fait
qu'on veut faire passer des mecs devant
la Cour pénale internationale et qu'on
veut même pas voir cette espèce de
façade extraordinaire qui a été cette ce
mensonge public qu'on a délivré à la
tribune générale de l'ONU en disant les
armes de destruction massive iraakienne
et donc on va justifier l'intervention
euh c'est d'autant plus extraordinaire
cette espèce de mémoire autoeffaçable
c'est comme les ardoises des gosses
c'est que quand les les Russes ont
annexé la Crimée il y a eu un discours
de Kerry secrétaire d'État disant c'est
inadmissible qu'au 21e siècle un état
enfaillisse le territoire d'un État
souverain c'est c'est un Américain qui
disait ça alors que la première guerre
du 21e siècle c'est l'invasion de l'IRAC
bon donc c'est pour vous dire que je
pourrais être diplomate c'estàd je
pourrais facilement dire une chose
auquel je ne crois pas du tout c'est pas
grave du moment qu'on a la puissance de
la parole la Libye c'est tellement grave
et tellement insécure aujourd'hui que
même BHL n'y va plus c'est veut dire si
la situation est grave bon on a réussi à
mettre une pagaille terrible et donc la
Syrie a les mêmes caractéristiqu que ces
crises c'est-à-dire dès que l'état a
disparu se retrouve des logiques
internes qui peuvent être des logiques
qui peuvent être des logiques ethniques
qui peuvent être des logiques
religieuses mais dans lesquelles notre
légitimité à nous soit membr permanent
du Conseil de sécurité soit puissance de
la bienfaisance soit pays des droits de
l'homme est nul aujourd'hui il y a une
guerre qui part du Pakistan
l'Afghanistan l'Irak la Syrie le Yémen
Bahrain et la Somalie la Somalie et le
Nigéria dans lesquel les chiites et les
sunite se massacre est-ce que vous
pensez une minute que nous chevalier
blanc on va arriver au milieu de tout ça
en disant non non non mais nous allons
rétablir la situation et donc la Syrie
c'est l'exemple même de de dossier dans
lequel au lieu de partir d'une analyse
de la situation on a dit non non il faut
faire respecter les grands principes et
donc on est aujourd'hui dans cette
situation vous avez d'un côté les Russes
qui disent mais le seul moyen de ne pas
avoir la crise libyenne c'est de sauver
Assad et là ils ont une certaine
constance prestation annexe et disent de
toute façon si on peut tuer les les
russophones qui sont sur place ça nous
arrange parce qu'ils reviendront pas
chez nous donc il continueront à
bombarder et puis nous on a à côté de ça
effectivement la au début on a hésité
vous souvenez en début on disait non non
mais Assad c'est le mal il faut
absolument qu'Assad s'en aille on a même
eu un ministre qui a expliqué ça devtre
il y a 4 5 ans qui passerait pas l'hiver
Assad bon il est toujours là il montre
une certaine solidité pour une raison
assez simple c'est que c'est un état
multireligieux et que donc vous avez
effectivement un agrégat autour de Assad
qui sont des minorités qui craignent
d'être massacrés si daesh prend le
pouvoir et donc on est parti sur quelque
chose qui était alors ensuite on avait
effectivement l'idée d'exclure les
Iraniens ces gens-là ils étaient pas
fréquentables donc on faisait quand même
des conférence internationale dans
lesquel on n'invitait pas l'Iran ce qui
était quand même une caractéristique
assez intéressante on en avait besoin
pour l'Afghanistan pour l'Irak et pour
la Syrie mais c'est pas grave c'est nous
qui gérons l'agenda international donc
voyez c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est
devenu un pays de moyen impuissance
c'est qu'on a des diplomates qui
continuent à dessiner une carte du monde
comme on l'aurait fait au au 20e siècle
au début du 9e siècle en disant mais non
vous allez voir on va régler les choses
comme ça quand
j'entends le discours public disant nous
avons des responsabilités historiques en
Syrie si notre respons ilité c'est
d'avoir fait le plan Saico je crois
qu'il vaudrait mieux qu'on la ferme
parce qu'en fait c'est ce découpage de
deux états artificiels qui étit la Syrie
et l'IRAC qui sont nés des mandats
français et britanniques qui sont des
États qui finalement n'ont survécu que
parce qu'il y avait des dictatures donc
prétendre que nos responsabilité
historique c'est quoi c'est de
reconstituer ces états qui n'avaient pas
de logique de politique qui avait la
logique de la dictature bon au lieu de
partir d'une analyse politique en se
disant qu'est-ce qu'on peut
effectivement faire comment est-ce qu'on
peut gérer la crise comment est-ce qu'on
peut contribuer à la marche on est parti
flamberg Jovent en disant non non non il
faut bombarder Assad s'il utilise ses
armes chimiques j'ai jamais compris
comment on pouvait empêcher
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques en
bombardant des sites chimiques parce
qu'en général quand on bombarde des
sites chimiques on fait des morts dans
l'entourage des sites chimiques mais
enfin c'est pas grave il y avait
peut-être un truc que je connaissais pas
et vous avez vu la prudence des Anglais
des Britanniques ils ont dit euh on a
suffisamment payé avec l'Irak on a
suffisamment payé avec l'Afghanistan la
Syrie pas tout de suite l'armée
britannique est sortie épuisée de d'irac
hein épuisée c'est la raison pour
laquelle les Anglais ont hésité au début
à venir dans la coalition internationale
la Libye et Sarkozi quand certains
journaux affirment que Sarkozi est parti
en Libye pour des considérations
personnelles votre avis là-dessus je
sais pas je le connais pas d'assez près
je peux pas dire c'est fort possible je
sais pas je sais pas du tout je veux pas
me rentrer là-dedans parce que j'ai
aucune preuve donc je vais dire oui il y
a des journaux qui le disent lui il va
dire le contraire non je crois que il y
a une chose qu'on qu'on mesure mal c'est
la facilité avec laquelle un gouvernant
peut se trouver invité par quelqu'un qui
ensuite qu'il regrettera ensuite dont il
regrettera par la suite d'avoir accepté
l'invitation c'est r marie avec Benali
c'est des choses comme ça bon donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe effectivement
derrière je peux pas dire je peux pas
dire j'en sais rien il y a une époque où
quand Saddam Hussein était notre
meilleur allié dans la région il y avait
effectivement un défilé de digitaire qui
allait en Irak
régulièrement qu'est-ce qui va se passer
si la Syrie tombe
c'est une bonne
question d'abord moi mon mon principe
consiste à dire que c'est une crise
régionale dans laquelle les acteurs de
la région doivent s'entendre et c'est
nous qui sommes en train de la
mondialiser c'est-à-dire il y a des
crises sur lesquelles on n'est pas
capable d'intervenir la crise la plus
meurtrière depuis la fin de la Seconde
Guerre du mondiale c'est la crise du
Congo 2 millions et demi de morts 13000
enfants enlevés pour faire des esclaves
sexuels des porteurs des des enfants
soldats et cetera je crois pas que ça a
jamais fait la une du d'un d'un grand j
quotidien bon donc il y reste cette
espèce d'interrogation pourquoi la
Syrie il reste qu'effectivement euh
c'est une crise qui pose la question de
toute la légitimité des pouvoirs des
découpages religieux dans la région de
la façon de gérer la chose de
l'implication des pays de la région pour
trouver une solution pacifique à la
crise bon or aujourd'hui on n'est pas
dans des logique régionale de recherche
de la pacification puisque l'Arabie
Saoudite va va sur comment dire aider
une partie des des combattants en Syrie
l'Iran va aider une autre partie et
cetera or est-ce à nous de venir au
milieu de tout ça il a une logique de
guerre régionale pour laquelle
effectivement si c'est un comme je le
pense une guerre sunnite
chiite nous on a mis un siècle à
découvert la tolérance il a fallu qu'on
se massacre comme des fous entre
protestants et catholiques et encore
aujourd'hui on a le solld de avec la
guerre en Irlande qui est la crise la
plus ancienne de territoire européen
c'est-à-dire la dimension religieuse des
crises est une dimension très visqueuse
dans laquelle on ne peut difficilement
intervenir quand on n pas soit la
puissance soit une légitimité forte bon
voyez bien cl si l'Arabie Saoudite nous
disait je vais envoyer des casques verts
pour séparer les catholiques et les
protestants on dirait mais qu'est-ce que
c'est vous rendez pas compte qu'est-ce
que il est fou bon or nous on est dans
cette logique c'est-àdire on dit non non
mais nous nous avons des responsabilités
mondiales on a plus les moyens de ces
responsabilités mondiales je vais vous
citer un exemple plutôt je vais vous
faire un développement de nature
stratégique à partir de la décennie 90
il y a une pensée stratégique américaine
qui se met en place s'appelle la
révolution dans les affaires militaires
la révolution dans les affaires
militaires part du postulat que les
technologies qu'on est en train de
découvrir vont permettre de faire des
armes suffisamment précises qui vont
permettre de frapper à distance de
sécurité qui vont permettre de limiter
la frappe à l'objectif qui est
précisément désigné qui vont permettre
la transparence du champ de bataille et
cetera et cetera toutes choses qui vont
donner effectivement naissance à des
armes très technologiques avec des
missiles de précision avec des avions
descollants des États-Unis pour aller
bombarder l'Irak et cetera et cetera et
effectivement le principe c'est le zéro
mort en tant zéro mort en tant soldat
occidental he évidemment
euh dommages collatéraux limités au
maximum dommages collatéraux c'est pour
expliquer qu'une bombe de 500 kg quand
ça tombe sur une maison en général ça ne
tue pas que le terroriste mais enfin bon
ça fait partie de dommages collatéraux
euh et donc on avait quelque chose qui
sur le plan stratégique a donné
naissance à la professionnalisation de
toutes les armées occidentales
c'est-à-dire des avions parfaitement
équipés pour faire ce genre de mission
et cetera en face de ça il y a eu une
deuxième révolution stratégique dont on
n pas vu qu'on a pas vu naître mais
parce qu'elle s'est jamais formalisé sur
des documents c'est tout le contretype
de ces principes là
c'està-dire l'idée d'aller faire la
guerre chez l'autre puisqu'on a la
distance de sécurité on peut frapper à
distance on peut faire de la projection
de force bon l'autre daesh ben il vient
faire la guerre chez nous puisquil sait
que là-bas il peut pas la gagner par
contre ici il sait que c'est la
fragilité c'est le territoire national
c'est le 11 septembre avec alqaïda c'est
les attentats terroristes ici l'idée de
faire le zéro mort occidental c'est vrai
il y a pas de soldats français qui sont
morts simplement il y a 280 français qui
ont été tués dans des attentats plus 500
blessés donc ça veut bien dire qu'on est
dans une guerre où il y a pas de mort en
uniforme mais par contre il y a des
morts civiles en face de la protection
du soldat du Zéro mort le type dit mais
moi je peux vous mettre des cicasses qui
sont prêt à se sacrifier qui de toute
façon vous atteindront parce que nous on
s'en fout de nos notre sacrifice est
supérieur à à la protection de vos
soldats bon et donc on a des les
principes exact par exemple la
transparence du champ de bataille ça
veut dire que avec les systèmes
interception et cetera on est capable de
connaître la stratégie de l'autre le
problème c'est que l'autre il veut pas
se battre il veut pas de champ de
bataille il transpose le champ de
bataille ici et donc tous ces contetypes
stratégiques montrent que ce qu'on
croyait être une espèce de percée
conceptuelle de la pensée stratégique
est en fait aujourd'hui retourné par des
principes appliqués par daesh et qui
montre nos fragilités c'est du hacking
dans la dans la guerre je sais pas si
c'est du H King non je crois que c'est
des gens intelligents vous savez le en
général dans la guerre c'est celui qui a
perdu la guerre précédente qui
renouvelle la stratégie he c'est pas
celui qui la gagne parce que celui qui
l'a perdu il se dit comment il faut
faire pour ne pas valoriser les
arguments de l'autre bon on va parler on
va parler un peu de stratégie comme vous
évoquez le
terrorisme je vous résume ça d'une façon
un peu décousu un camion de 19
tonnes qui fait un repérage du moins le
le le propriétaire du le camicas fait un
repérage pendant une année vient faire
un rad rage sur la Promenade des Anglais
avec un 19 19 tonnes
vide la version officielle est mise à
mal par des
journaux parce que la transparence au
niveau de l'enquête est un peu remise en
cause quand vous avez une voiture près
de Montparnasse qui est retrouvé avec
sans plaqu d'immatriculation avec des
warnings six bouteilles de gaz à
l'intérieur et ensuite une cellule de
femme se fait attraper est-ce que pour
vous c'est un message est-ce que c'est
un message de voilà nous sommes
infiltrés sur le territoire nous sommes
capables de faire des repérages du
renseignement de terrain et de faire
rouler un camion 19 tonnes vide mais on
écrase tout le monde nous sommes
capables de vous montrer que nous avons
des cellules de femmes et on vous met
une voiture avec six bouteilles de gaz à
la rigueur on aurait pu mettre des
plaques de RACA histoire de vous appeler
plus vite la voiture est signalé qu'au
bout de tr/4 d'heure 1 heure ou mais un
certain temps est-ce que vous pensez que
ce qu'on appelle les terroristes font du
renseignement de terrain et ont un plan
diplomatique pour faire passer des
messages euh moi je qualifierais pas l'
tentat de list de repérage he je veux
dire c'est des repérages pour pour
exécution quand même c'était pas pour
dire regardez on est là et on vous
laisse une preuve qu'on est passé par là
non c'était du repérage destiné à faire
ce qui s'est passé le 14 juillet
c'est-à-dire écraser le maximum de gens
bon je pense également que la tenta
enfin les les bouteilles de gaz dans le
dans le coffre était effectivement aussi
la volonté de faire exploser quelque
chose donc dessus si parce que si si non
c'est beaucoup plus simple il y avait un
truc de mazoute il y avait un verre de
truc de gazoile bon on le gazoil on fou
le fa au gasoil au bout d'un certain
temps les les trucs explosent non le
paradoxe c'est que s'il y avait eu un
conducteur au volant aucun policier
n'aurait eu le droit d'ouvrir le coffre
c'est ça le l'état du droit aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire même avec l'état d'urgence
ah ben même avec l'état d'urgence oui il
aurait fallu qu'il demande à un juge le
droit deouvrir un véhicule parce que
c'est du domicile privé le véhicule donc
là je sors d'une réun union mais je vous
en raconte pas le le truc mais on est on
est véritablement dans un espèce de
comment dire il y a un anglais qui nous
a qualifier de manière assez
intéressante il dit ce pays qui aime
temps les idées c'est-à-dire la réalité
des faits on s'en Foutin attention il
faut qu'on parle des principes et donc
aujourd'hui on dit qu'on est en guerre
mais simplement sur des choses aussi
futiles que le simplement la possibilité
s'il a un véhicule abandonné d'ouvrir le
coffre si jamais le conducteur est au
bout si le type veut pas l'ouvrir ce
genre de chose on a vu le cas réaliser
où effectivement il y aurait pu avoir un
attentat euh sur ce qui concerne le
renseignement de terrain moi je
travaille en ce moment sur le la revue
francophone de daesh qui s'appelle Dar
l'islam bon effectivement il y a
quelqu'un ici qui contribue à la
rédaction de Dar et l'islam c'estàd
quelqu'un qui fournit des analyses pour
montrer qu'ils sont des intellectuels
qui partag les vues daesh qui sont
capables de montrer comment réagit la
société française au attendat de
novembre et cetera donc de toute façon
daesh a toutes les capacités à faire du
renseignement de terrain ici parce que
encore une fois la le comment dire la
pénétration salafiste qu'on n pas voulu
voir pendant des années est aujourd'hui
très très présente dans le territoire
français bon dans quelle proportion on
estime qu'il y a à peu près 12 entre 12
et 15000 salafistes aujourd'hui en
France salafiste alors encore une fois
c'est un qualificatif j'ai difficile
parce que c'est pas écrit sur la carte
d'identité mais ça veut dire de gens qui
aujourd'hui vivent dans des agrégats
dans lequels il y a une stratégie de
ghettoïation c'est-à-dire comment est-ce
qu'on constitue des endroits dans
lesquels on coupera cette partie de la
Communauté française musulmane du reste
de la société alors comment ça se passe
ben ça se passe avec une stratégie
politico-rigieuse c'est-à-dire qu'à
chaque fois qu'on fait une revendication
on explique que si la République refuse
cette revendication c'est parce qu'il
aime pas l'islam alors c'est très
astucieux je prendre un exemple piscine
de lîle vous connaissez tous l'histoire
la mairie de Lille à un moment à la
demande de femmes qui obèes ou de femmes
qui voulaient pas être embêté à la
piscine demande des heures réservées aux
femmes bon la mairie accorde et puis
comme la piscine est dans le sud de la
de la de la ville il y a des femmes
musulmanes du quartier qui demande à
s'inscrire puisque c'est des déjà
réservé aux femmes bon puis ensuite elle
demande qu'on obture les BA vitré parce
que on peut les voir de l'extérieur puis
ensuite elle demande que tout le
personnel soit musulman ou en tout cas
que ce soi des hommes puis ensuite elle
demande que ce soit des heures réservées
c'est ça la stratégie politico religieus
de des salafistes c'est-à-dire comment
est-ce qu'à un moment on va présenter un
refus de la République ou d'une autorité
publique comme une activité qui refuse
les droits de l'islam moi j'ai été
invité au salon du Bourger et il y a une
femme qui m'a posé qui m'a dit mais moi
la République m'empêche d'aller à la
piscine je dis madame c'est pas la
République il vous empêche à la piscine
c'est votre religion ne confondez pas ne
renversez pas la charge de la preuve
parce que encore une fois les salafistes
considèrent que la loi de Dieu est
supérieure à la loi de la République
donc il est pas question d'obéir à la à
des des règles de contrainte ou des
règles d'application qui vont leur être
présentés par leurs penseurs comme
quelque chose qui est évidemment dicté
par le Coran bon lecture du Coran
caractéristique des salafistes c'estàd
lecture littéraliste dans lequel on dit
mais si c'estcr comme ça c'est que rien
n'a bougé rien doit avoir bougé depuis
tout le reste c'est une perveion
perversion de la la lecture du Prophète
donc on est aujourd'hui avec un un un
fivier salafiste qui est en France assez
important il est d'autant plus important
et notre notre société d'autant plus
fragile que la France est le pays qui a
la plus grosse communauté musulmane la
plus grosse communauté juive la plus
grosse communauté chinoise la plus
grosse communauté arménienne de tous les
pays de l'Union européenne c'est-à-dire
c'est un pays intégrateur et qui a des
problèmes avec une partie de la
communauté musulmane que sont les
salafistes or tout le discours consiste
à dire notre modèle d'intégration ne
fonctionne plus c'est quand même assez
paradoxal c'est-à-dire que c'est un pays
qui justement a intégré et continue à
intégré parce qu'il y a toute une élite
de la communauté musulmane qui
aujourd'hui fournit ses artistes ses
écrivains ses acteurs de théâtre ses ses
cadres moyens ses banquiers ses
entrepreneurs et cetera mais quand même
la vue est focalisée sur cette partie là
qui est la partie la plus urti de la
société française bon et donc le
discours politique pendant longtemps
consistait à dire nous avons la loi 1905
et donc nous avons nous sommes un pays
laïque donc on a un espèce de
barrage en fait on a laissé faire on a
laissé faire beaucoup de choses on s'est
laisser enfermer dans une espèce de
problématique de la mise en accusation
du modèle laïque français en disant
c'est
islamophobe
le fondamentalement la chose a changé
avec les attentats c'est-à-dire que les
attentats ont fait tout à coup un espèce
de basculement de opinion publique
française qu'on a par exemple constaté
dans les entreprises c'est-à-dire que
dans les entreprises par exemple j'ai vu
le cas dans les enfin j'ai entendu le
cas de la RATP qui par exemple avait à
un certain moment des demandes tout à
fait légitimes de par exemple de salle
de prière dans des lieux de repos bon
lap accorder les salles de prière mais
par exemple dans le 93 où il y a une
forte communauté musulmane notamment
beaucoup de conducteurs musulmans après
les types ont dit oui mais on veut pas
serrer la main des femmes donc du coup
la RATP a dit bon ben serre plus la main
dans les ateliers ce qui est quand même
assez surprenant puis ensuite ça a été
mais on veut pas être sous l'autorité
d'une femme puis après maintenant
dernière revendication c'est on veut pas
s'asseoir dans un bus qui a été conduit
par une femme avant donc voyez on a une
espèce de logique de la progression pour
la ghettoisation c'est-à-dire il y a un
moment où il faut que nos règles
s'imposent bon le basculement s fait
avec les attentats notamment après
novemb où tout à coup on dit bon ça
suffit maintenant il faut effectivement
remettre les choses à ple notre
situation est moins pire que d'autres
pays euh
lesquel le je prends le cas de la la
Ligue Islamique mondiale a été le bras
armé de la diplomatie religieuse
saoudienne la Ligue islamique mondiale a
été créée à l'époque où les pays du Golf
avaient très peur de Naser Nasser
c'était le nationalisme arabe c'était le
socialisme arabe et cetera et Nasser
avait des mots très durs contre les pays
du Golfe donc il crée la Ligue arabe il
s'appuie sur l'université Alazar pour
faire un islam
moderniste il
crée il y a un troisème structure qu'il
crée mais en face à laquelle l'Arabie sa
et puis il va évidemment prodiguer le
panarabisme bon son discours va marcher
puisqueeffectivement il va marcher en
Libye en Syrie en Irak les parties
basses il va marcher en Algérie et
cetera l'Arabie Saoudite est très
inquiète et donc pour contrer cette
diplomatie nassérienne elle va créer la
Ligue islamique mondiale pour faire
front à la Ligue arabe elle va pronner
le panislamisme pour répondre au
panarabisme et puis elle va créer
l'université islamique de Médine pour
faire le pendan à l'université d'alazar
bon et donc la Ligue islamique mondiale
et le bras armé de l'action diplomatique
saoudienne la Ligue islamique mondiale a
fait dans les années 2000 j'ai oublié la
date je le cite dans le bouquin mais un
congrès au Canada dont la thématique
était comment faire avancer l'islam dans
les pays occidentaux et ils arrivent à
la conclusion que le bon modèle c'est le
pays communautariste donc il prenit
l'exemple de Belgique l'Angleterre du
Canada et cetera en disant si des
communautés ont des droits les musulmans
doivent avoir les mêmes ce qui sur le
plan juridique est inattaquable bon et
donc la revendication de la Ligue
islamique mondiale s'est traduit en
particulier par la demande de création
d'écoes coranique et la création de
tribunaux islamiques au Canada les
Ukrainiens par exemple ont de droit
civil qui leur est propre donc ils ont
leurs tribunaux donc la revendication de
la de la Ligue islamique mondiale
c'était d'avoir le pendan pour la
communauté musulmane quel est le
problème qu'on a constaté c'est que par
exemple en Angleterre ou aux États-Unis
on s'est aperçu que dans les écoles qui
sont financées par la Ligue islamique
mondiale c'est le programme saoudien qui
s'applique programme saoudien
c'est-à-dire racisme sexisme en je vous
fais pas la liste il suffit de se
reporter on prend toutes les case noire
et c'est tout bon voyage colère c'est
pélerinage à la MEC interdiction de fête
et les les fêtes religieuses non
musulmanes enfin tout ça bon donc en
fait une école qui fabrique des bons
démocrates avec du racisme du sexisme de
l'antisémitisme de l'homophobie de la
mise donc ça a alerté les structures de
contrôle quand même en Angleterre il y a
des rapports de la du corps d'inspection
qui sont très sévères sur ces écoles
coraniques tribunaux islamiques ça
partait là aussi d'une idée assez simple
c'est effectivement le droit civil est
un droit qui peut-être inspiré de la
charia et donc des musulmans qui veulent
respecter la charia peuvent très bien
être jugés par des tribunaux
islamiques le problème c'est que
notamment dans le droit du divorce ou
dans le droit du du mariage si vous
voulez dans le droit coranique si vous
frappez votre memme c'est du droit civil
si vous au Canada si vous frappez votre
femme c'est du droit pénal donc c'est
pas tout à fait il y avait des problèmes
de contradiction entre les les droits et
donc au Canada ils sont revenus
complètement en arrière parce queils
sont aperçus qu'en fait ces
revendications qui paraissaient
légitimes donnaient lieu en fait à des
diffusion d'idées qui étaaient
totalement antirépublicaine
anticonstitutionnelle et cetera donc
nous dans ce sens-là on a été protégé
par le fait qu'on a toujours refusé les
revendications corporatistes et même un
ministre de l'Intérieur a refusé que la
Ligue islamique mondiale soit admise au
CFCM au Conseil français du culte
musulman donc ça nous a protégé dans une
certaine mesure parce qu'on a jamais eu
à accepter des on n jamais accepté quoi
que ce soit correspond des écoles
coraniques gérées par l'Arabie Saoudite
ni des écoles ni des tribunaux
islamiques mais en même temps ça nous a
value l'accusation d'islamophobe puisque
évidemment si on refuse ça c'est qu'on
ne peut être que islamophobe donc dans
ce sens ca ça a été le bilan qu'on a est
à la fois positif et négatif
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement le fait de
se barrer de se défendre derrière la loi
1905 nous a interdit de véritablement
réfléchir sur ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est l'affaire du voile un
exemple très
caractéristique
euh dans les années 2000 il y a un
professeur au Collège de France un type
formidable qui s'appelait Mohamed Arkoun
qui est un type vraiment de haute volée
qui dit il faut créer en France une
faculté de théologie musulmaneon
demande étonnement général dans
l'université française qu'est-ce qu' lui
prend l'université islamique il en est
pas question et cetera
bon le type disait une chose très simple
il disait aujourd'hui pour un théologien
musulman moderniste il ne peut
travailler tranquillement que dans une
démocratie il est pas question d'aller
travailler à Lazar il est pas question
d'aller travailler à la zituna à Tunis
il est pas question d'aller travailler à
forciuré à Médine donc il faisait un
appel à l'aide vis-à-vis de la
démocratie française pour dire
aidez-nous parce que encore une fois il
faut que on puisse former des imams il
faut qu'on puisse former et cetera
toutes questions qui vont sortir avec
les attentats il faut qu'on puisse
former des imams français il faut qu'on
puisse aider à créer des homoniers
musulmans dans les prisons et cetera
donc sa demande était tout à fait pleine
de bon sens il était même allé à
Strasbourg parce qu'il disait Strasbourg
il y a le Concordat en Alsace donc on
peut puisque le l'Université de
Strasbourg forme les pasteurs on peut
effectivement formmer des imames dans le
cadre du Concordat et il devait avoir
rendez-vous avec Jospin mais un
conseiller bien avisé de josp a dit non
non il faut surtout pas recevoir ce type
donc on a tué le projet mais on a le tué
on l'a tué par bêtisse alors que c'était
la situation face à laquelle on se
trouve en janvier 2015 en disant mais
comment il y a pas d'omonier musulmans
en prison comment on n'est pas capable
de former des imams français et cetera
VO donc on était dans cette situation où
la loi 1905 nous servait à répondre à
toutes questions tu vois c'était comme
marché je ne sais pas quelle est la
question mais la réponse est non tu vois
et donc on était dans cette situation et
tout à coup le le barrage s'est écroulé
et donc tout à coup tous ces problèmes
qu'on ne voulait pas résoudre en disant
mais la France ne financera pas le la
formation d'imam et ceetera on s'est dit
mais si il faut le faire voilà donc ce
principe de réalité il a été en comment
dire malheureusement imposé par les
attentats vous parlez d'attentat
euh le prochain se matérialisera sous
quelle forme à votre avis oh ben la
stratégie du terroristme c'est toujours
de choisir l'endroit qui est le moins
protégé et qui va être le plus médiatisé
la définition de de Chalan et de hararon
sur le terrorisme est la version la plus
simple c'est-à-dire le terrorisme est un
acte de violence dont l'effet
psychologique et médiatique est
supérieur à l'effet stratégique voilà ça
veut dire on va pas les États-Unis sont
pas écroulés après le 11 septembre par
contre effectivement l'effet médiatique
et psychologique a été gigantesque donc
par nature le terroriste a toujours
l'initiative du choix de l'endroit et de
la modalité puisqu'on peut mettre des
soldats absolument partout toute façon
ce sera peut-être sur un match de
football de 2e division ou ce sera
peut-être pardon aringis ça peut être
aringis ça peut être n'importe où la
question encore une fois c'est d'être
sûr de médiatiser complètement personne
pouvait imaginer le le le scénario du 14
juillet à Nice je suis pas d'accord
bah peut-être enfin c'est plus facile à
postériori de dire que c'était c'était
prévisible je sais pas moi je suis pas
les services de renseignement ils ont
droit comme ils sont obligés de se taire
ils ont toujours droit à un procès en
général à postérieur parce qu' vous
faites pas votre
boulot ils font très très bien leur
boulot pardon ils font très très bien
leur boulot bah oui justement donc dire
qu' n'ont pas prévu ou dire qu'ils n'ont
pas pu empêcher c'est mal connaître le
métier du renseignement quoi
nonfin moi quand je suis face au bilan
français c'est-à-dire 250 morts et plus
de 800 blessés en 18 mois et aucun
soldat français tué je seraai
personnellement en droit de m'interroger
pour savoir si notre diplomatie est
adaptée mais aujourd'hui la question
n'est pas posée le seul ministère qui ne
s'est livré à aucune autocritique après
les attentats de janvier novembre c'est
le K
doré pour vous le on est en en campagne
pour 2017 ouais pour vous qui est le le
meilleur candidat pour gérer le
problème ça alors vraiment je aucune
idée parce que je les connais pas
suffisamment d'assez
près ce que ce dont j'ai très peur c'est
que la campagne électorale donne lieu à
une surencher sécuritaire c'est-à-dire à
quelque chose qui soit avec moi il y
aurait pas d'attentat ce que personne ne
peut légitimement pr prévoir ou alors de
dire il faut faire des camps de des des
petits Guantanamo à la
française ça peut être on peut avoir ce
genre de proposition on a même V dans un
moment de délire quelqu'un qui proposait
qu'on équipe de de RPG7 des des forces
de sécurité qui onouré des
manifestations pour empêcher le scénario
du camion suicide non je crois que je
crois que
malheureusement un RPG il faut expliquer
peut-être tout le monde ne sait pas ce
que c'est oui RPG c'est un c'est ce
c'est le l'arme portative antichar
c'estd celle LC c'est ça pardon un
lance-roquette antichar oui c'est ça
c'est un lance-roquette antichar et donc
l'idée c'est on peut arrêter un camion
qui se précipite bon mais c'est pas
grave je dire ça ça fait partie de la
comment dire de
la du stress médiatique que crée le
l'attentat sur l'homme politique mais ce
que je crains donc c'est que le débat de
fond soit évité sur le thème par la
sécurité en disant il faut faire c il
faut faire ça faut mettre tous les
fichiers machin et cetera euh
alors que le véritable problème c'est
encore une fois c'est de réfléchir à
notre propre politique notamment à notre
propre diplomatie quand on voit sur un
site salafiste 1 Mor à Gaza on fait rien
quatre occidentaux égorgés on envoie
l'armée qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à
ça rien c'est-à-dire que véritablement
on a un système de double standard qui
Hite tous les musulmans pas seulement
les salafistes ce double standard il est
évidemment toujours de se dire mais dès
qu'il y a un truc dans le monde arabe de
toute façon on va envoyer de l'armée bon
donc on revient à quelque chose qui est
qui est fondamental à mon avis dans le
débat politique mais qui aujourd'hui je
ne vois pas beaucoup poter c'est il faut
probablement revoir notre politique
extérieure et notre manière d'envoyer du
militaire à chaque fois qu'on sait pas
quoi faire les flux de migrants alors
les flux de migrants c'est un c'est une
situation effectivement qui est très
dramatique humainement moi évidemment
comme je m'occupe plutôt de la région je
suis plus scandalisé par le fait que les
pays du Golf n'accueillent pas de
migrants
euh et il que l'Arabie Saoudite
accueille un million de de réfugiés non
l'Arabie Saoudite accueille des réfugiés
mais en les triant c'est-à-dire l'Arabie
Saoudite n'a jamais signé les
conventions internationales des droits
sur les réfugiés vous savez ces
conventions ont été signées dans les
années 50 parce que tous les pays
occidentaux se reprochaient d'avoir
refusé des Juifs à patride que Hitler
avait déchu de leur nationalité et donc
chacun essayait de se le refiler les
Américains prenaient les premières
mesures antimigrants les Français les
autres et cetera bon donc quand on signe
les conventions internationales sur les
réfugiés en dans les années 50 on dit
les pays signataires s'engagent à ne pas
refuser un réfugié quelque ce soit sa
nationalité sa religion son sexe et
cetera et ceetera bon vous imaginez bien
que l'Arabie Saoudite qui déjà
n'accueille aucun aucun autre religion
sur son sol va pas prendre des yazidis
ou des ou des chrétiens fuyant l'Irak ou
la Syrie donc ils sont capables de trier
ce qui est absolument scandaleux ensuite
1 million à l'échelle de l'Arabie
Saoudite c'estàdire quatre fois moins
que ce que fait le Liban
et donc je serais curieux de savoir
pourquoi l'Arabie Saoudite qui a de
l'espace de l'argent et la gestion du du
pèlerinage ça fait quand même 2 millions
de personnes qui arrivent comme ça sur
une période courte en Arabie Saoudite
pourquoi ce pays n'accueille pas donc il
préfère financer les camps de réfugiés
en Jordani au Liban en Turquie que de
les prendre chez eux ce qui est une
hypocrisie que l'Europe pourrait
dénoncer vous savez le le roi d'Arabie
Saoudite quand Angela Merkel a proposé
d'accueillir 1 million de de
réfugiés gentiment proposé de la
construction de 200 mosquées en
Allemagne pour que les réfugiés puissent
quand même pratiquer leur religion ça a
fait un peu sauter le vicechancelier qui
dit mais il y en a assez de ce pays qui
passe son temps à de cette
extraordinaire hypocrisie donc ils
disent qu'ils accueillent un million de
réfugiés mais encore une fois c'est pas
des réfugiés c'est on prend ce qu'on
veut et c'est le contraire même de la du
principe du réfugié qu'est-ce qu'ils
font des autres qu'ils n'acceptent pas
ah ben les pauvres ils n'envisagent même
pas de venir parce que les les
héritréens les Éthiopiens vous imaginez
qui vont aller en Arabie Saoudite comme
eux-mêmes expulsent les Somaliens et des
gens comme ça c'est-à-dire que par
exemple l'Arabie saoudite à chaque fois
qu'il y a une baisse des prix du pétrole
et qu' y a un problème de de ressources
ils ont une technique assez simple ils
expulsent les travailleurs immigrés
comme les travailleurs immigrés font
tout dans ce pays qui ne payent pas
d'ailleurs je crois bien ah ben ça
dépend ça des fois c'est privé des fois
c'est public mais celle-là c'était
plutôt des cas de salariés d'entreprise
privée bon dans les années passées il
leur est arrivé comme ça d'expulser un
million de Somaliens éthiopiens éitriens
c'est quand même une manière euh é
original de de de régler la question du
suremploi par exemple donc ils espèrent
dégager des emplois pour des Saoudiens
mais les Saoudiens travaillent pas donc
c'est une espèce de contradiction parce
que quand on est dans un pays rentier
par définition la rente ça sert à faire
travailler les autres dans le les
entreprises saoudiennes 95 % des CADES
sont étrangers donc il y a ce volet de
pouvoir expulser des gens mais
évidemment on ne sait qu'on ne pourra
pas les leur substituer des Saoudiens
donc pour revenir à la question il tri
encore une fois il y a des gens ne
viennent pas parce qu'ils savent que de
toute façon toutç ils seront pas ils
seront pas acceptés vous savez moi il y
a un truc qui m'a frappé sur la je me
suis posé la question de savoir quelle
était la différence entre le salafisme
et le wabisme bon il y en a aucune il y
a deux petites nuances quand même qui
sont
intéressantes la première c'est que
l'Arabie Saoudite donc fait venir des
cadres religieux pour les former à
l'université de Médine
et ça c'est son université lououba si on
doit la comparer avec un autre grand
système de
propagandiste dans le contrat que signne
les Bour
que parfois l'Arabie Saoudite va
débaucher à Lazar c'està-dire qu'ils
envoient des gens en disant mais venez
donc chez nous parce Queau moins chez
nous vous aurez une bourse alors qu'
Lazar il y en a pas vous serez logé
alors que vous serez pas logé et ceteron
donc il déboche des gens pour les faire
venir chez eux mais dans le contrat qui
signe il y a l'obligation de retourner
ensuite dans son pays pour faire de la
prédication ça veut dire la uma c'est
bien mais si vous avez le passeport
saoudien c'est mieux donc contrairement
à ce qui se dit l'Arabie Saoudite tous
les musulmans savent que c'est pas le le
pays de l'islam c'est le pays des saouia
enfin des gens qui ont un passeport
Saoudi la deuxième différence entre
daesh et l'Arabie Saoudite effectivement
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler ça ftiste
c'estàdire les oulas sont là pour dire
surtout pas d'attentat sur le territoire
ça c'est ça c'est haram ça c'est pas
bien voilà c'est ça alors il y a un truc
qui est très original quand même c'est
que les Saoudiens se ventent par exemple
d'avoir un programme de déradicalisation
très
efficace 95 % de réussite pourquoi on
l'exporte pas en France ah ben attendez
parce que le problème il est assez
simple c'est de transformer des sal la
fiste en wabit donc évidemment on peut
avoir 95 % de réussite dans ce cas-là
c'est pas vraiment le programme
transposable en France les fl de migrant
en France comment on va les gérer ça
j'avoue que je sais pas j'avoue que
c'est très c'est une question
extrêmement difficile surtout que on
sait qu'on n pas arrêté la pompe quand
même hein non il y en a on en a ACC que
30000 là cette année c'est ça 3 je sais
pas je connais pas les chiffres donc la
question des migrants je la connais pas
bien ce qui est certain c'est qu'on n
pas arrêté le on n pas arrêté le le flux
d' tant que dans les migrants il y a des
réfugiés de la guerre mais il y a aussi
des réfugiés économiques et puis il y a
évidemment une partie des mecs qui ont
fait les attentats de novembre aussi
donc ça fait beaucoup de questions à
gérer en même temps quoi le au niveau de
du renseignement et du traitement de des
fichesses des des signalements comment
ça se passe en France je sais pas je
peux pas répondre à ça moi je suis pas
dans les services je sais pas comment ça
se
passe le le fichier s c'est un fichier
qui qui retient des choses de nature
très différent ça peut être soit des
gens soupçonnés de salafisme avec
préparation attentat terroriste ça peut
être un trafiquant de drogue ça peut
être
euh ça peut être toute forme de
délinquence c'est pas c'est pas
seulement terrorismeciste un écologiste
non je sais pas je sais pas je pas le
sentiment bon cela dit il faut bien
reconnaître que dans le domaine de la
violence il y a quand même des
manifestations qui se sont traduites par
des phénomènes de violence qui ont
strictement rien à voir avec l'Islam
pour lesquels on est en droit de
s'inquiéter quand même parce que si y un
NotreDame des land il y a des mecs qui
balancent des bouteilles d'acide sur des
policiers ou des cocktails
molotop personnellement je pense pas que
ce soit la on a on a dépassé les limites
du débat démocratique quand même vous
vous voyez une radicalisation de la
population française face à la
radicalisation de de l'Islam radicallam
Oui oui les radicalismes fonctionnent en
miroir hein de toute façon s'il y a un
radicalisme d'un côté il y a un
radicalisme de l'autre euh la montée du
Front national est aussi expliqué en
partie par ce fait et ce qui est très
original dans le vote du Front national
c'est qu'il y a des musulmans qui F de
Front national parce qu'ils disent il y
en a assez que à chaque fois on parle de
l'islam pour parler des salafistes et
donc ils disent Mo le Front National a
une logique claire alors on n'est pas
d'accord avec les mesures mais par
exemple le le débat sur le mariage pour
tous a été alimenté notamment VO les
manifestations contre la loi à la fois
par des associations catholiques et par
des associations musulmanes comment ça
va se traduire dans le domaine du vote
ça se traduire par le fait que Hollande
est élu avec 80 % du vote musulman et en
fait on va avoir probablement
aujourd'hui une une répartition beaucoup
plus significative du vote sur
l'ensemble de la du champ est
probablement plus à droite qu'à gauche
donc on est dans cette situation où la
montée des radicalismes se font en
miroir hein c'est-à-dire vous avez à la
fois les identitaire d'un côté les
salafistes de l'autre et cetera et c'est
vrai que si le débat politique il est en
train de se centrer aujourd'hui sur le
thème qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
réprimer pour réprimer ou pour encadrer
non pour réprimer c'est-à-dire comment
est-ce qu'on arrête cette propagation du
du salafisme dans la dans le monde
musulman donc ça suppose une analyse
sociologique de ses mécanismes de
diffusion de ses subventions et cetera
et cetera vous savez qu'en France on a
aucune loi par exemple qui permette à la
Cour des comptes ou à l'Inspection des
finances de contrôler une association
qui reçoit des subventions de l'étranger
c'est-à-dire que on peut vraiment pas
mettre les non non il y a aucun droit si
c'est une association à but non
lucratif personne n'a le droit de
s'emmer qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
général Picmal qui a été radié des
cadres de l'armée pour une organisation
de manifestation antimigrant
rien enfin la République a fonctionné il
a dépassé les clous il a été Radi des C
de l'armée ou ENF il devait en deè
section d'ailleurs je crois non il était
déjà en retraite déjà en retraite non
ENF je veux dire la République a
fonctionné ce qui aurait été grave été
grave c'est qu'effectivement il soit
dans les cadres encore et que
effectivement on pense qu'il y avait
dans l'armée des gens qui étai sur et le
fait de lui interdire de porter
l'uniforme de reporter l'uniforme je sa
pas est-ce que ça va
radicalisere une
frange de droite française ben la
radicalisation de fait elle existe mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit la frange
traditionnelle de droite
traditionnaliste le problème de la
poussée du frond national c'est que
c'est l'ancienne électorat du PC parce
que paradoxalement les gens qui sont au
contact de ce bouleversement que
représente la poussée du salafisme moi
j'ai une ancienne secrétaire qui me
tient régulièrement au courant de ce qui
se passe dans son quartier elle habite
au bervilliers depuis des années et
c'est ces gens-là qui vont
paradoxalement voter Front national
parce qu'encore une fois vous avez dans
le 5e 6e 7è arrondissement des gens qui
vous font de la théorie et puis en fait
vous avez des gens qui vivent leur
quotidienneté avec les difficultés que
ça représente donc le le vote du Fond
national c'est un vote populaire si vous
aviez laissé un conseil pour les jeunes
générations moi j'avoue que je suis un
peu désespéré parce que ma génération
c'était celle du militantisme pour la
libération des
femmes on constate que dans les départs
en Syrie il y a 30 % de femmes qui
parfois Marie par internet donc là il y
a une espèce de Gap que j'ai du mal à
expliquer euh il y a une espèce de
comment dire
de de rejet de la la vie démocratique
puisque dans les conversions par exemple
il y a un basculement dans un système
totalitaire où tout à coup on a une on a
l'adhésion à un système qui est
véritablement révolutionnaire c'est
comment changer tout le système bon
or je trouve que notre système est
incapable de se réformer c'est-à-dire on
a un parlement dans lequel on a une une
dép qui vote avec un bracelet
électronique c'est énorme ça on a un mec
qui a appris que les impôts existaient
il l'a découvert quand il a fail être
nommé secrétaire d'État et on a un
député maire de Levallois qui a un
nombre de class rô tel qu'on dirait un
jeune marié bon à côté de ça on a
effectivement donc une classe politique
est incapable de
sanctionner la
corruption les mecs peuvent redevenir
députés et cetera on a un corp
électorale qui est réélit quand même
faut pas oublier
ça on a là aussi mais c'est pas propre à
la la France j'étais dans une réunion de
patron je leur ai dit mais à chaque fois
qu'un patron se vente de l'augmentation
qu'il s'est fait donner au lieu de se
venter du nombre d'emplois qu'il a créé
vous faites partir des mecs en Syrie
parce que votre société est injuste les
mecs étaient soufflé qu'on leur disent
ça en face bon mais c'est ça notre
société c'est-à-dire c'est une société
de l'hypocrisie qui se vend sous le
principe de l'individualisme et on
s'étonne que des jeunes se disent mais
moi je pars dans un projet collectif bon
donc si j'avais un message à adresser ce
serait au vieux con qui nous dirige
plutôt qu'au jeunes parce que que les
jeunes ils le subissent ce système ils
le subissent la réussite individuelle
regardez combien gagne un tel combien
gagne un tel et cetera quand vous avez
des mecs qui sont à la 3oè génération de
chômeurs on peut comprendre que ça
finisse par les irriter cette cette
société mais elle est très satisfaite
d'elle-même
elle est la société de la futilité
regardez ce qu'a fait Rihana par rapport
à ce qu'a fait machin par exemple un
truc qui est quand il y a eu le scandale
d'Abou GB vous souenez la prison bon
dans lequel des soldats américains
hommes et femmes humiliés des iraakiens
mis en prison en les couvertantouverant
en les couvrant d'excréments enfin en
les humiliant publiquement et C et bon
la question qui était posée au
fond c'est que dans la société
américaine mettre un mec à nu à la
limite bon ça fait partie d'une
technique d'interrogatoire classique
mais dans la société musulmane la
dessence est une est un principe et
l'indessence n'est pas obligatoirement
une valeur donc ce qui a beaucoup
sensibilisé dans la rue arabe c'est le
fait que on puisse humilier des hommes
chefs de famille devant des soldats pour
rien simplement pour les humilier et
donc se demander à certains moment si
nos valeurs sont véritablement les
valeurs qu'on doit diffuser partout sur
la planète ça supposerait un examen
critique qu'on n pas prêt à faire pour
finir mon bouquin je suis allé dans un
pays charmant qui s'appelle le kyrgistan
je vous dis pas où c'est parce que vous
rechercherez sur la carte le kygizistan
est un pays qui est né donc de
l'éclatement de l'URSS euh et je
discutais avec l'ambassadeur
donc c'est un pays d'une dizaine de
millions d'habitants composés de kirgis
d'ousbec de Tadic et cetera VO
euh l'ambassadeur m'expliqua qu'il avait
reçu instruction du K d'orsé de
solliciter de demander aux autorités
politiques locales qu'elle a étit le
droit des LGBT en
kirgisistan il a dit non j'y suis pas
allé B voilà on est dans un monde où on
se dit mais attendez il faut quand même
expliquer au monde entier quelles sont
les véritables
valeurs je crois pas que la question des
quand
quandand ils ont suffisamment d'esèmes
quand quand en France on on vous
reproche d'être dans un conseil
d'administration pour un pays de de
l'exunion soviétique où il y a un
dictateur à la tête là comment comment
ça s'appelle du kyrgistan non de quoi
genre je me rappelle plus du pays vous
faites pas partie d'un d'un conseil
d'administration qui met en avant le un
pays de l'acion soviétique ah non moi je
suis adhérant d'une association qui
s'appelle l'association des Amis de
l'Azerbaïdjan voilà alors j'ai essayé
d'expliquer parce qu'un jour il y a un
journaliste qui m'a posé la question moi
j'emmène des entreprises dans un pays
pétrolier j'emène des entreprises
françaises hein bon j'estime que c'est
mon boulot euh une des entreprises que
j'ai amené fabrique des nutriments pour
le bétail je suis pas sûr que ça pose
des grands problèmes d'atteintte aux
droits de l'hommeon et donc on est dans
cette situation vous avez des gens qui
ici sans bouger leur cul qui contribuent
nullement à ce que l'économie française
se dynamis vous explique attention ce
que vous faites n'est pas bien mais j'ai
été vendre des armes en Arabie Saoudite
en d'autres temp j'ai été vendre des
armes dans un certain nombre de pays du
monde donc il y a un momentù il faut
arrêter de penser que tout notre critère
de jugement ça va être de savoir si les
gens avec lesqu on signne sont bons ou
pas parce que si on se réduit à discuter
uniquement avec les démocraties d'abord
il y a aucune démocratie qui pratique ça
aucune hein un pays comme l'Allemagne
nous a dépassé plusieurs années en
matière d'exportation d'armement
personne ne s'est plein en Allemagne de
savoir donc on est sur des si je vous
dis ce type cet anglais qui a écrit ce
bouquin sur ce pays qui aime tempant les
idées c'est une caractériistique du
système français on vous explique
attention à ce que vous faites c'est
vraiment pas bien mais euh descendez sur
mon ami descendez sur terre qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait pour améliorer les
choses d'abord je pense qu'il faudrait
que nos
élites d'abord une des originalités du
système administratif français c'est
qu'on peut être contrôleur sans jamais
avoir été acteur quand on sort bien de
l'enat on va direct au Conseil d'État la
Cour des comptes ou l'Inspection des
finances c'est quand même original on
pourrait penser que c'était le cas
enunion soviétique si on avait la carte
du parti mais non là c'est le système
français bon donc une administration
dans laquelle il vaut m être contrôleur
cacteur c'est pas une administration qui
va être en prise sur la réalité
puisqu'on risque de se faire sanctionné
par quelqu'un qui a jamais travaillé bon
euh ensuite il y a quelques principes
comme ça qui sont des principes aberrant
de la société française moi j'ai été
j'ai travaillé 5 ans dans les tribunaux
administratifs alors par exemple dans le
droit administratif français un silence
de l'administration vous demandez un
truc il y a pas y a silence ça peut être
soit une décision de refus soit une
décision de d'accord soit pas de
décision du tout je prends les exemples
aux impôts vous estimer que on vous a
demandé trop d'impôt vous écrivez on
vous répond pas faut quand même payer ça
veut dire ça équivut à une décision de
refus rejet de votre lettre vous êtes en
permis de construire demander un permis
de construire au bout d'un certain temps
vous vous l'accorde pas si on vous
l'accorde pas ça veut dire que vous
l'avez donc c'est une décision positive
quand l'État vous doit de l'argent et
que le dossier est sous le cû du
contrôleur financier si le contrôleur
financier ne fait rien il y a aucune
décision qui n'est ça veut dire que dans
ce cas-là vous ne pouvez strictement
rien faire donc quand vous êtes dans un
système où au lieu de dire c'est
l'inaction qui est sanctionné vous avez
un système dans lequel l'administré ne
peut rien comprendre parce qu'on va dire
attendez j'ai demandé on m'a dit oui
l'autre fois on m'a demandé ça veut dire
non l'autre fois je demande ça veut rien
dire du tout bon donc on est dans un
système dont il faudrait revoir les
fondements pour que c cette ce système
s'adapte à la réalité quand je vous dis
par exemple que sur l'affaire de la
voiture avec les cinq bonbonnes de gaz
un policier n'aurait pas eu le droit
d'ouvrir le coffre ça vous montre
combien notre droit est un droit du
principe et non pas un droit de la
réalité c'est pas une violation des
droits de l'homme que savoir si dans un
état d'urgence un policier il peut
ouvrir le coffre d'une voiture
abandonnée sans avoir un sol citer un
juge qui est lui-même est surchargé de
boulot qui va regarder s'il faut
accorder le truc avant que la la voiture
n'explose ça ça peut aussi nous protéger
de certains abus
oui mais le paradoxe aujourd'hui c'est
que l'abus n'est pas obligatoirement
celui de l'État aujourd'hui des
entreprises comme Google Yao et cetera
ont beaucoup plus de pouvoirs que
n'importe quel état pour contrôler notre
vie privée enfin vous le savez mieux que
moi donc on est dans un truc où on a un
héritage c'est une persistance
rétinienne on appelle ça vous savez ça
date de l'époque du communisme où on
pensait que le monstre c'était l'État
mais l'état on l'a [__] dans ses modes
d'action au point parfois de le rendre
totalement inefficace et puis par contre
on peut avoir des acteurs privés qui ont
des pouvoirs qui sont très largement
supérieur enfin assang je l'a
suffisamment montré c'estàd qu'il y a
effectivement des tas de trucs on l'a vu
avec Yo régulièrement on s'est aperçu
qu' Yao fournit ses données à la NSA
donc on est dans un système où les
acteurs privés peuvent être aussi
dangereux que les acteurs publics donc
il faut qu'on revoie un peu notre
logiciel est-ce que vous avez des
questions à nous poser non moi j'aime
bien le boulot que vous faites par est
que c'est un espace d'expression libre
et surtout euh je suis un peu je suis
effrayé par le politiquement correct je
suis effrayé je vais vous citer un
exemple parce que je le cite toujours
celui-là et je trouve qu'il est
désespérant à l'époque Sarkozy le
gouvernement proposait le rapprochement
des fichiers génétiqu de la gendarmerie
et de la police il y a une levée de
bouclier comment atteintte aux droits de
l'homme comment des libertés publies et
cetera entre le
débat et le moment où les Fichi ont
étaient rapproché c'est passé 2 ans
pendant lesqueles gu George l'assassin
du 19e a tué deux femmes en les violents
j'ai jamais entendu un défenseur des
droits de l'homme s'excuser parce que
c'était pas une atteinte aux droits de
l'homme parce que le rapprochement des
fichiers génétiques on a découvert que
ces fichiers étaient dans les les stocks
de la gendarmerie qui n'avait pas le
droit de les communiquer à la police
donc on est sur un monde qui est
totalement décalé c'est devenu une
profession à temps plein d'être
défenseur des droits de l'homme
aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi peut-être
nécessaire dans le sens où la la
situation économique française se
complique que partout en Europe des
gouvernements un petit peu radicaux sont
en train d'émerger et que c'est
peut-être aussi nécessaire de faire
attention à ce type d'émergence de
d'État plus totalitaire que d'habitude
oui mais le la définition de droits de
l'homme est une définition
fondamentalement nationale prendre un
exemple les anglais pendant longtemps la
carte d'identité ou les Américains la
carte d'identité il en est pas question
parce que c'est un contrôle de l'État
sur la vie privée bon
euh eux ils avaient des caméras partout
bon nous on a dit le caméra quand même
chez nous c'est pas bien c'est du la
surveillance de la vie privée par contre
la carte d'identité c'est pas un
problème voyez vous avez un de choc
entre deux vieilles démocraties dans
lesqueles chacun dit les atteintes aux
droits de l'homme c'est ça et l'autre il
dit non c'est le contraire voyez donc
encore une fois c'est une définition qui
doit nécessiter d'être une confrontation
entre des principes et une réalité c'est
pas une posture dans laquelle on va se
mettre comme ça débat aussi pareil avec
les défenseurs de l'espace de liberté
que constitue internet qui juste
justement pour contrôler les sites
salafistes disait mais c'est une
atteinte au droits de l'homme mais on
est capable de faire de l'intrusion sur
des sites
pédophiles et pourquoi le fait-on pas
sur des sites salafistes alors qu'on
sait que c'est pas les pédophiles qui
vont tuer 84 personnes sur la promenade
des anglais donc le degré de dangérosité
sur le deuxième sujet beaucoup plus
grave que sur le premier il est grave de
toute façon sur les pédophiles mais
c'est pour dire combien par moment il
faut qu'un moment on rapproche le degré
de dangérosité d'une situation avec une
autre moi j'ai participé à un débat dans
lequel sur la de où il y avait euh
maréchal Le Pen le maire et puis
Mélenchon ils sont engueulé sur le
danger que représentait le Front
national or on était à une semaine après
les attentats du Bataclan et les
attentats de novembre donc jetais leur
dire mais excusez-moi mais vous êtes sûr
que vous êtes en train de vous de vous
rapprocher d'une réalité qui est celle
de ce danger terroriste c'est pas le
Front National qui a tué une quarantaine
de personnes au Bataclan et puis
qu'est-ce que vous êtes prêt à sacrifier
euh en fonction de la réalité si dure
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à sacrifier
votre liberté d'expression si la la
réalité
l'impose mais de toute façon on la
sacrifie tous notre liberté d'expression
quand on est au courant d'une opération
de police par exemple d'une opération
antiterroriste qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
va aller vite au journal pour dire
regardez des policiers qui se
rapprochent de cette maison on le fait
tous soi-même en tant que citoyen donc
je veux dire c'est pas un principe en me
disant si on me disait vous n'avez pas
le droit de dire
ça encore faut-il me savoir qu'est-ce
que contient le message pour savoir si
j'ai le droit ou pas mais le on a vu le
cas par exemple avec Assange quand il a
sorti tous les documents montrant les
intrusions de la NSA dans la vie privée
qui que le c'est Snowden Snowden quand
il a montré toutes les quandassang
montré tous les les excès en Irak et
cetera bon collatéral damage hein
collatéral damage oui là à ce moment-là
vous aviez des des gouvernants qui
disaient mais c'est inadmissible
l'action publique doit nécessiter un
minimum de secret mais dis non non c'est
pas vrai c'est le contraire l'action
publique a au contraire besoin de
transparence notamment quand tu est en
situation de guerre parce que les
motivations de la guerre et les
modalités d'action c'est absolument
essentiel tandis que là on est dans un
système où les hommes politiques disent
mais ça ne se passera pas comme ça nous
allons envoyer l'armée et cetera ce qui
est exactement la connerie qu'il faut
pas faire quand on est dans face à un
truc terroriste moi j'ai toujours en
tête le l'exemple du début de la guerre
d'Algérie un couple d'instituteurs dans
les ores qui allait rejoindre leur
postees l'autobus est arrêté le les
premiers fedaga tuent les le coupe
d'instituteur à ce moment-là toute la
classe politique se lève unie ça ne se
passera pas comme ça nous allons envoyer
l'armée vous connaissez la suite la fin
du match bon et donc on est dans des
situations comme celle-là la liberté
d'expression c'est un moment de dire
mais attendez excusez-moi il faut
peut-être réfléchir avant d'agir mais ça
veut dire que le tempô médiatique peut
pas être celui qu'il est aujourd'hui le
typô politique peut pas être celui qu'il
est aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on retrouve des hommes d'État je sais
pas comment ça nit les hommes d'État
pierre connais ça merci merci à vous
[Musique]